all right um some general tips for
everyone
um and bear with me because the UK that
I have here they they're not they're not
trained in this uh what I have come to
call fedorite iido uh the only fedorite
I have here is Shan okay Sean's not here
tonight um so I got to kind of Coach
them into demonstrating the point I want
to make okay so uh let's say for
example that UK is standing right there
okay and I want to move him over one
meter to this line over here
okay
um modern iido has this thing that they
call leading okay um um and the way that
I Define all of this is that's an that's
an an an example of the choreography and
then the way I Define
choreography is that the reconciling of
Yin and yangong is placed upon UK uh
that is not how we train here the
reconciling of
yinong is placed upon nag okay so um if
this is my UK and I am trying to apply a
technique on them that requires them to
be moved from position a to position
B um I'll give you the examples
abstractly of the modern UK who
reconciles the energy okay so here's
position a and I want to move him to
position b a meter over to his right
so some of the things that we do is he's
going to follow my hand you see um we
don't want that we don't we
don't um lead UK they don't
fill the yin space they they don't do
that okay
uh that's just wrong okay then but
however uh the the other one
is um UK also does not let's
say that I'm pushing
him right I'll do it
okay he has the intention of pushing me
over there I don't also don't just go
okay so walk walk me over there walk me
I'm not doing this okay
I and what I'm doing here is uh if you
pay attention as he's walking me over
I'm walking to keep that
okay what would what would normally
happen is if I leave my feet here and he
pushed above my center of gravity my
head would tilt go ahead and you would
see that instead okay
um as opposed to he's walking me over
and I'm walking like that that that is
me still
reconciling the uh Yang energy
okay but we also so I don't want my UK
doing that I don't want them reconciling
the yin and yang either way positively
or negatively but I also don't want my
UK in Kon waza
as he's trying to push doing this stuff
okay um I don't want them changing the
force equation that is given in the in
the moment uh at all so I don't want
them generating higher Y and also he's
trying to push me I don't want them to
do
that change changing the force value
that's what that is do you see uh and he
goes and I don't want to doing this I
don't want them to change the force
value if you pay
attention in my first
example this is his Force value and UK
is changing the force
value if UK does not change the force
value nothing happens you
see and
likewise when I'm pushing above the
center of
gravity UK doesn't change anything so
that's why he
[Music]
tilts for UK to walk himself over there
is changing the force value he's doing
that and
likewise the force Force value is here
and if you get turns to get off of it
that is changing the force value I don't
want ukit to change the force value
either positively or negatively
okay now this is hard for people to
understand so
um because modern iido in the fact that
it's a choreo
choreography has more
moralized and uh
labeled UK's ability to reconcile or
UK's assigned responsibility to do the
reconciling of Yin and yangong they have
moralized it and they have
uh put symbolic capital on it so the
ones the ukas that can do that more and
are willing to do it more they will have
higher rank they'll be the ukas for the
teachers eventually they get known and
eventually they get the seminar circuit
etc etc okay uh and the UK who
don't uh they're and they have
a beating coming and we're all going to
treat them like in the dojo and
stuff like that and we're going to say
they don't get it and you see we we're
going to negatively treat them label
them and assign them uh negative capital
that's what's happening so it's very
very hard so most of the
times um here at our Dojo when the UK
does any changing of the force that's
what we
ostracize so um that's where you see me
uh not throw them um or flat out uh
change the technique on them or extend
where they thought thought we were going
uh or flat out yell at them uh and
things that you probably haven't seen is
I just smack the out of them after
a while um some of them get kicked out
uh on our failure to respond to training
protocol um because either way that's
the problem we don't do that
okay um
so if you're do doing for example koku
ho okay and uh he's coming
in and here we have this force in the
ferite so here here the ferite already
starts to go backwards you
see and uh versus what we do which he's
going to bring me around and forward see
as he's doing uh the ferite version okay
and I'm
here I he has some tilts but as he goes
backwards I'm here and I don't have to
change the energy he he just runs into
that energy do I look like I'm trying
I'm not trying but I'm stand handy
that's all that's
happening what the fedorite UK will
do is at the pressure coming back they
will do
that if he's going
forward like K nag from ten con okay
they'll go like that you
see but we we wouldn't change the
pressure so as meaning this is my
relationship as he goes to
throw and it takes no effort to do that
it's not you're not being an but
nothing affected the bottom of my
body so that's the result okay it's very
similar to
this if I want to move him that one m i
pick him
up and I moved him a meter he did not
have to try he did not fight it right so
he didn't drop his weight and make it
extra hard for me but I moved him a
meter
okay so as you guys are trying our
techniques you have to be careful of
your old style of Emi
where he goes and then you're
this okay because if the UK does that
you will not see the need for what we do
instead and so you won't do what we do
instead and you're still practicing
something that is fake
okay um fakeness is not as innocent as
we think it's not the problem with
fakeness isn't that your art is not
Marshal the problem with fakeness is
the role that delusion plays in the
construction of self and you are in a
practice that is involving the
deconstruction of self so you cannot
separate um the deconstruction of self
from The Pursuit Of Truth
if you are doing something superficial
masquerade fraudulent
faral uh the self is always going to be
the driving force for the shape that
takes and therefore the self is being
reified and constructed through farce
through fabrication through
superficiality okay so it's not so
innocent when we stop our Pursuit Of
Truth and we start doing something else
okay okay that's the real problem so uh
when I do this and uh again I got to
show what to do um when you feel that
pressure he bent his back and you see
this Bo in his back we that is a sign
that this is okay people do not
bow their backs that are attacking you
um they do everything they can to not
bend their backs okay so if you pay
attention in our throwing
architectures um their back stays
straight we don't try to bend their
backs okay so kinaga for example he
doesn't Bend his back
please he doesn't do that uh and then I
get my mechanical leverage to throw him
uh so if you you and this is something
that's easily observable as you're
practicing uh did my UK bend their back
in that bow shape or bent forward in
that bow shape then chances are they
reconciled the uh technique then chances
are I'm doing a different geometry a
different throwing architecture than
what Dave is doing okay so um and here's
why if you pay attention and you go here
there's no freaking mechanical advantage
here um I I can't do
against him there's no way but if
he bends his back enough then then I can
I can get that going okay um can you can
you do that can you just spend your back
okay so I I I touch you back and then
and now I feel like I'm I am so doing do
you see um but it's not as far as
self-construct uh it's okay
what we do
instead is I get a tilt and that is the
contention point and so that's that's
what I have to turn this straight line I
have to spiral rotate this um tonden and
not push back and not expect him to bow
for me okay and we have this same thing
so uh
uh this is rampid in every video
everyone sending me but um because you
guys were kind enough to send them uh
Karen and Noah I would look for that and
then uh Kathy and Ivan I would I would
look for it too okay uh and again if
you're trying to learn the architectures
if he
bows then you throw this one but we
don't do that I have to spiral rotate
the
270°
um in in my throwing architectures which
I have to do to get that tonden turning
to change my Consciousness okay
um EO is something else like here here I
go right and you see how he's bending
forward like that okay and we'll take it
because it put the elbow so low that I
can get on top of it and use gravity to
make that work
okay um and you don't that's not what
you're trying to do in the technique so
if you pay attention on tensin I just
that tilt that's it that's all I need to
start spiral rotating his Center into
the throws that you saw in that recent
video so I don't need his so compromised
to throw and
likewise when I'm in his Center this
elbow isn't going to get all the way
down to where I can get on top of it
okay so don't sit here and try to get
that to to wear it's down like
that you're going to generate the same
turn the same tilt in his body so look
how high it is so don't try you don't
try to shove this down same way but from
the front I have to spiral rotate this
Center so I don't push this out that way
I don't try to push it down I take it to
270°
and it
lowers on its own
so just like I'm not chucking his head
into cling
net I'm just staying with his
head there's nothing in my arm the same
thing goes here in eel I'm not shoving
this down I'm bringing it around and I'm
just staying with it that's all I'm
doing okay
um I think What's blocking you now from
fully gaining our architectures is that
old
Reliance uh on UK
reconciling the yinong interaction don't
don't okay so
likewise
um the um let's say you do the titano
hand coat okay so I'm
and he he would feel that
push on me there's a there's a don't
move this time and you this is what I'm
doing so he reconciles that
cool and if he goes ahead of me go I
don't go like
that and that's that's what the modern
UK with you so he he goes ahead of me
and then they go like that like we no
that's not it okay um the UK who Moved
ahead of you just like gave their back
okay no don't give their backs okay um
and this applies to if he's doing our
tyo heno okay so I push and I'm not
going to walk myself around so watch
watch
me again he goes you see I'm
walking I am changing
the force equations I just do the spinal
displacement again what's that look like
it looks like
this he does what he
does and this is where I
am this is me trying to get control and
and change it and if you pay
attention while not as
extreme it's
there in the other
one my spine stays
straight which what happens in real
assaults okay
um I think this is pling what we're
doing in tenin Ty heno and what we're
doing in EO okay think think about it a
little more rewatch the videos where
those were specifically
generated uh uh or address the
anatomical positioning and then um try
to not do anything anymore as UK you the
only thing you
do where you have agency as UK is the
initial
prescription that is it after that don't
positively or negatively affect the
force equations allow what's happening
to happen okay don't make things happen
don't assist things happen um no not not
not correct okay